Speaker 1: You know, just yesterday we talked
about. The definition of freedom that the right
adheres to right now is very authoritarian.
The freedom to deny other people things,
the freedom to tell others what it is they can and
can't do. The freedom, you know, we talked about
that yesterday. There's another element to this
authoritarian slide that I think deserves its own
discussion, which is that the Republican Party is
moving in the direction of pulling out of future
presidential debates. The Republican National
Committee says it will require candidates to
pledge to not participate in debates run by the
Commission on Presidential Debates. What would
replace them, if anything, was unclear. This is
an extraordinarily authoritarian move. Now there's
sort of like the logical reason why they would do
this. And then there's the reality that it fits
into this bigger authoritarian picture, and we'll
go through both of those aspects in a second.
The New York Times reporter Maggie Haberman
reported the RNC is preparing to change its rules
to require presidential candidates that want to be
a Republican nominee to pledge not to participate
in what have historically been the official
presidential debates sponsored by the Commission
on Presidential Debates. Republican committee
officials A letter alerted the debate commission
to their plans in a letter sent Thursday. If the
change goes forward, it would be one of the most
substantial shifts in how presidential and vice
presidential debates have been conducted since
the commission began organizing debates more than
30 years ago. The nonprofit commission was founded
by the two parties in 1987. It codified debates
as a permanent part of presidential elections,
describes itself as nonpartisan. Republicans have
complained for a decade that the process favored
Democrats. The move by the RNC was an outgrowth of
those long-held complaints and came after months
of discussions between the commission and party
officials. This discussion apparently started
last year. The Republican Party chairwoman, Ronna
McDaniel, demanded changes be made to how debates
were held. The change requiring candidates to
refuse participation is to be voted on at the RNC
winter meeting in February. If they move forward,
it's unclear what that means for future debates.
So there are two pieces to this. OK, first,
let's talk about the sort of like, Well, yeah,
if you have no issue based
platform on which you would debate,
why would you debate? And what I mean by that
is increasingly started with, I mean, listen,
I'm not going to do the whole thing, but this
started a really long time ago, but more acutely.
George W. Bush became less and less issue focused
and more kind of ideology based when Barack Obama
became president. Republicans went completely
crazy and abandoned policy 90 percent. And then
under Trump, there's been no more policy at all.
If you don't have policy on which to debate,
why would you go to a debate? OK? That sort of
makes sense. But then it goes further if you're
not trying to win on the issues, right? If you're
winning on trying to win, on gerrymandering,
voter suppression, bogus post-election
tactics, legal challenges and the like.
Debates don't really have a part in that.
You don't really need to convince people to
vote for you. And the third piece of this is
that this is very on brand in terms of being
autocratic and authoritarian. And former David
Pakman show guest Ruth Ben Guyot wrote a really
good piece in her Substack called demagogs Don't
debate the GOP mimics Putin and Orban refusing
to participate in presidential debates is
a symptom of the Republican's embrace of
authoritarianism. This is a really good article
to check out a good blog post from Ruth Benguela,
who writes debates between presidential
candidates enact the democratic principle
of mutual tolerance. The notion that those who
don't share your political views have a right to
free expression. The public here's an exchange
of views by two individuals on equal footing,
bound by the same rules enforced by an impartial
arbiter when they say we're not going to do that
anymore. It furthers this idea that no one they
people with political disagreements can't even
be in the same room as each other, but also is the
furtherance of other aspects of authoritarianism.
Personality cults, as Ruth Benjy writes, posit
the leader as a man above all others. The
egalitarian staging and format of debates makes
them dangerous to his brand. Since authoritarian,
sustained power through disinformation, threat,
corruption and fixing elections. Who knows what
might be exposed if they submit to spontaneous
questioning by a rival or a third party?
And that is a fundamental aspect of this, and I
won't read Ruth's entire post. But she talks about
Putin understanding this and his history of
refusing to debate and talks about Orban,
a Putin client who. Followed that lead, or
Auburn, hasn't debated since 16 years ago
after a really bad performance in a 2006 debate.
So there's two aspects of this and there is the.
They don't run on policy, so why even talk to the
opposition? Sure, that's fair. But then there's
also yet another way in this which in which this
idea of not getting on stage with your opponent
mimics and mirrors that which we've
seen other authoritarian strongmen do
around the world over the last 20 years. So very
much on brand with this extreme authoritarian,
dictatorial slide that we've seen from the
Republican Party. The Republican Party will
vote next month as to whether they are finalizing
this decision not to participate in the debates.
My instinct is they're going to do it. I don't
think this, you know, it seems like the type of
thing they would kind of decide beforehand. Do we
have the votes for it? But we'll see next month,
and we'll tell you when there is an ultimate
decision made by them. In the meantime,
you can let me know your thoughts about this
wildly autocratic decision by finding me on
Twitter at De Packman. Our program is mostly
funded by viewers and listeners through the
David Pakman Show membership page, which you
can find at joint Packman dot com, we do an
extra show every day for our members. And I would
love it if you signed up at join Packman dot com.